time to talk about the game that you've
been planning for 10 hours or no sorry
yeah 10 hours you played ten hours did I
have destiny rise of irons newest
expansion I don't know but we need to be
clear this is the second time he's
played this stuff cuz you already played
it yeah an event like two weeks ago so i
went to bungee i was lucky enough to be
sent there to kind of like a review
event almost because you were out of
town so we we wanted to get some
coverage out of it features or video but
that felt rushed I felt like I I got
through the story which fortunately
isn't too long I actually liked the
story I think it was a cool kind of
concept I just didn't last that long by
about a 90 minute maybe our sorry 90
minute maybe to our type ordeal and then
a lot of the what the rise of irony is
comes after that so you know you
explored the plague lands you do our
cards Forge which is like a new kind of
court of wars prison well there's hybrid
that's kind of faster that's like nine
players public event yeah in the patrol
area and and then the raid obviously
Friday we have no idea i didn't get to
touch the raid at all so at that event
it was a little bit rushed or trying to
do different things capture different
things just didn't have enough time kind
of going through it more today um say
it's okay I think like I said the
story's pretty pretty good but short I
think the rest of the stuff is kind of
the same ol same ol a little bit just in
a different world I I do like some of
the lore that's coming out of some of
these quests I like some of the quality
of life stuff they've added so it's like
they have a book that you can you know
go through if you finish it you're you
know you're getting tangible rewards
which helps kind of a casual player
who's playing you know maybe by
themselves or with one friend who can
actually do that maybe not be able to do
the raid they still have something to do
right I think those are all good things
really for me now at this point it's
just about the raids because the strikes
are kind of just remastered versions of
old ones that with twists and there's
like one new strike that's okay I mean
you've played some of it to nunya and
your
looking into doing a review in progress
I believe you know what are what are
some of your thoughts yeah it strikes me
more as DLC than actual expansion like
taking King was it's not revamping the
foundation of the game it's not actually
like changing how what I think about
destiny I do like that they're kind of
going for this almost like high fantasy
game of thrones that's kind of thing
which they've said like I remember them
saying like that the way they're telling
the story and trying to like this is how
they like justify like how shallow the
story was before they're saying we just
want to introduce details which we were
planning on going into depth with later
which is like you know like you've
learned all these characters and Game of
Thrones whoever and then you learn about
them like in an entire episode later on
in the next season but I it hasn't it
was like 90 minute campaign I believe I
might have gotten through it faster and
it's just going into Lord Saladin who
usually shows up for the iron banner
events it's detailing kind of what's
called Siva this like nano robot plague
and it's kind of got like hints of like
an allegory for like a nuke it was this
weapon that it was this thing that
people could have used to like create
anything it was like renewable energy
but then of course like the fallen and
like old fallen sects started using it
for ill and now you're kind of fighting
it back again I won't go into spoilers
what happens but it just kind of feels
like the story rushes by and I never
really got the impact of what was going
on which is always like a thing with
destiny I never had there was contacts
for what I was doing and I knew why I
was doing it but I never felt like I was
enjoying like the story pushing me along
it just felt like I was doing it for the
sake of getting through the missions and
getting that reward at the end yeah I
mean that like they're up there aren't
that many missions I mean one in
particular is really good but if you're
going to swallow territories I kind of
wish they'd use that to kind of mold the
rest of the stuff but you know it's hard
when I went up there they did say that
you know they start a production of rise
of iron like end of January you know so
hasn't been that long and they've kind
of kind of got a lot of stuff out there
even if you want to say it's a reskin
and stuff like that I'd I haven't gone
through enough of the quest stuff yet
too because there's for exotic weapon
quest I've done to today they're pretty
extensive if you want to get your year
three galler horn back again which is a
thing it took me probably as long as the
story like that's how long it felt like
it
took me so you know there are people
that are fixated on some of those past
experiences you know of galler horn and
and the fun they had with that and
they're gonna do that right that's
that's a good another hour and a half
and then like the cost kvass tov excuse
me the first gun you ever get in the
game they have an exotic version of that
fan almost like fan service cuz
everyone's always been asking for the
kvass cough and the the mission for
that's pretty like not bad it's pretty
good and there's a nice little nugget of
lore at the end that's kind of cool but
sometimes those moments feel few and far
between like yes you can feel it
sometimes like oh this is really cool
and then sometimes you're just like oh
yeah okay just kind of like plotting
along and doing things you did kind of
touch on it but I think I've played at
this point about five to six hours since
this morning and I think of that time
I've spent maybe 45 minutes in new areas
you know excluding the social area but
it's just you the for one of the first
mission to you your retreading the
ground that you just started the game in
back in what 2013-2014 like the very
beginning of the game and or area the
what the little outdoor area yeah before
you crawl across the wall and into the
wall but yeah it's not like the strikes
the new strike the Archon priest is kind
of a little novel like this ogres
chasing you around you can't hurt him
he's pretty much just this nuisance that
you're kind of trying to avoid while you
shoot the priest who's also obviously
very cable of defending himself the
other streak is us our strike as epics
perfected aesthetics prime who we fought
I don't even know how many times by this
point again it seems like twist its
reach reading a lot of what we already
seen I do like the aesthetic of the new
stuff though that like that fantasy kind
of climbing the mountain to fell winners
p the new social area I haven't done a
lot of archons for jobs I've done one
and again you said those are like when
you offer things up to the likes Eva to
the gods or dads it's pretty quick paced
fast action that's kind of what they
want it's like a mini horde mode a
little bit more frantic than that at
times because you know there's explosive
shanks and whatnot and as the tears get
higher does get harder of course that's
because you know level difference and
stuff like that if you're not a level is
obviously going to be harder i was doing
heroic strikes I think they're like 350
347 and some people were even lower than
that and people were just getting gived
and then dying really fast kind of
frustrating actually but yeah to be out
like for me the story and everything's
great I like it but ultimately I think
for me as a min max hardcore player the
rate is really what's going to tell you
how much i like about rise of iron it's
kind of been the case for you know a lot
of the previous dlc expansions and we'll
have to see that doesn't come out till
friday yeah hopefully we get to check it
out hopefully you get to check it out
yeah because it is a big part of like
these DLCs and expansions I feel like
it's like probably a good third of it
you know there's like i'll probably hold
separate team just making the raid i
think it's also like bungees best chance
to show off their level design and their
mission design and everything because
those are the most nuanced like how do
we kill his boss and then you beat him
it's like such a big deal then you get
to the next mini boss and obviously the
final boss is pretty like usually a very
intense battle and everything again yeah
I after what I played we're gonna have a
review in progress up soon we're gonna
wait until obviously the raid goes up
because that's the make-or-break thing
for me on friday but until then i'm sure
we'll all be working on getting our
light up so we have a decent raid team
going and hopefully and I mean like on a
side note because this is something that
normally affects reviews and Peter you
know best of all is a we both luckily
escaped q hell as I would like to call
it because when I was screaming there
was I think Xbox one was struggling I
think they were almost like had ps4
servers up first or something or
priority I don't I'm this is just
hearsay this or sorry sounds my site
info to me it's not it's not inside info
it's just observations and it seemed
like more people were struggling on
trying to hop on xbox one as well as ps4
and I I can't remember to this date that
they even had queues and it just reminds
me of a World of Warcraft thing where it
could totally like alter your experience
because I was pretty much just
apologizing to people in the stream I'm
like I'm really sorry I don't have any
privileges or anything to stream I just
got lucky i spammed got in that's kind
of how servers like for these kind of
games work once you're in you just don't
leave because you're screwed if you
leave and people are like I'm 30,000 and
Q which is kind of a insane if you think
about it like that's a lot of people
that are trying to play the game yeah I
got
I didn't have any problems getting in I
got booted off world a few times yeah
but never disconnected from Destiny's
server so luckily i have not had any
performance issue well I've had a few
but nothing nothing a game-breaking
major displace played a fair amount pvp
but couple hours today I'm between
supremacy and was the other note mode so
pharmacies the new ones the privacies a
new one that's like he'll confirm from
call did you have to pick up people's
tags need to actually get the kill to
count or get 2x point and everything
I've been playing Rumble and everything
and then I the one alluring aspect at
least as far as progression goes is the
the book of iron a record book of iron
jumping and that's where you know you're
actually doing these rise of iron quests
your kind of unlocking these tears that
are giving you the cool looking armor
that you know like we've been seeing on
the cover for how long now yeah it's
also one of those sweet like oh yeah
these are not achievements or chivos but
you know there's things that you see and
you're like okay I'm nine out of ninety
percent done I'm gonna finish that boom
work on the next you just I think it's
just a Nate sense at least for me when I
see something like oh I gotta finish
that or if I candle just that's called
OCD Eric you guys chores of you oh god I
got yours yeah obsessive chore disorder
yeah it's pretty true so anyway that is
Destiny's rise of iron expansion
presumably the last one for the last
major one for destiny that they've kind
of been hinting at for a while yeah
they're gonna fill it out with events
and stuff like that and I think the big
thing that everyone wants that has kind
of been talked about but hasn't been
like really confirmed is everyone just
wants to go back and do the raids sure
have them bring it up or something
something that would allow us to go back
and do the raids because everyone loves
baltinglass it was like the first one
everyone it's probably most people's
number one raid and I could see them
doing that because you got a big gap
between now next September's you can't
just fill those with no Halloween and
winter events so yeah wouldn't be
shocked yeah anyway so there's rise of
iron and in the meantime I'll be getting
my light level up kind of work on the
reviewing progress just go up soon and
then it's like we said the rate will be
up Friday following that will put up our
full review and that unfortunately is
all the time we have today
you